?
THAT'S WHAT WE DON'T KNOW.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE HAPPY TO BE
JOINED TONIGHT BY THE DEPUTY OF
"NEWSWEEK."
SHE'S SINGLEHANDEDLY RESPONSIBLE
FOR MAKING THAT MAGAZINE
READABLE ONCE IN A WHILE.
HAPPY SHE'S JOINING US TONIGHT.
IT'S TRUE!
NEVER THOUGHT I'D READ A
"NEWSWEEK" PIECE UNTIL YOU TOOK
OVER, SO THANK YOU FOR THAT.
CLEARLY THEY DECIDED THE HIVE
HAS TURNED ON THE QUEEN.
HOW DOES THIS PLAY OUT DO YOU
THINK?
>> YOU KNOW, TUCKER, FIRST OF
ALL, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HAVING ME AND A BIG MAZEL TOV,
CONGRATULATIONS FOR BEING THE
NUMBER ONE MOST-WATCHED SHOW
AMONG DEMOCRATS.
IT'S SUCH A PRIVILEGE TO BE HERE
WITH YOU.
WE GET TO TALK TO BOTH
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS AND
THAT'S VERY RELATED TO WHAT
WE'RE DISCUSSING HERE.
YOU KNOW, ME VIEW IS THAT THE --
MY VIEW IS THAT THE REASON THE
LIBERAL MEDIA IS TURNING ON
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS BECAUSE HE
FAILED AT THE ONE THING THEY
REALLY NEEDED HIM TO DO WHICH
WAS TO SUSTAIN THE FICTION THAT
THE BIG DIVIDE IN AMERICA IS
POLITICAL WHEN AS WHAT YOU KNOW
BECAUSE YOU COVER THIS EVERY
NIGHT ON YOUR SHOW, THE REAL
DIVIDE IS ABOUT CLASS AND ON A
HOST OF ISSUES FROM COVID TO
CRIME, TO INFLATION, TO THE ROLE
THE U.S. SHOULD BE PLAYING IN
THE WAR IN UKRAINE, YOUR
WORKING-CLASS AND MIDDLE-CLASS
AMERICANS WHO ARE REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS AREN'T DIVIDED ON
THESE ISSUES.
THEY'RE DIVIDED FROM THE ELITES
WHO CLAIM TO REPRESENT THEM BUT
THERE'S THAT YAWNING GULF
BETWEEN THE LIBERAL MEDIA,
ELITES AND THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
AND WHERE AVERAGE AMERICANS ON
BOTH PARTIES ARE AT.
I THINK PRESIDENT BIDEN WOULD
HELP THEM PAPER OVER THAT GAP.
WHAT'S HAPPENED, THOUGH, HE CAME
TO EMBODY IT.
THEY'RE DISTANCING THEMSELVES
FROM HIM TO HIDE FROM THEIR OWN
FAILURES, TUCKER.
>> YOU KNOW, IT'S SO SIMPLE THE
FORMULA THAT YOU JUST SUGGESTED.
IT'S SO OBVIOUS.
IF YOU HAD A PRESIDENT WHO WAS
TRULY MODERATE, TRULY INTERESTED
IN THE LIVES OF THE PEOPLE HE
REPRESENTED, WHO CARED ABOUT
PEOPLE MAKING $70,000 AND NOT
JUST PEOPLE WHO RUN AMAZON,
LIKE, YOU COULD WIN EVERY
ELECTION AND RULE FOREVER.
WHY DON'T THEY DO THAT?
>> I MEAN, IT'S SUCH A GREAT
QUESTION.
LAST NIGHT, YOU TALKED ABOUT
MONOPOLIES AND HOW ANYONE
RESISTS MONOPOLY RESISTS POWER.
THE LIBERAL ELITES IN THE MEDIA
AND DEMOCRATS HAVE GOTTEN A LOT
OF POWER BY CONSOLIDATING AROUND
THE CLASS THEY SHARE.
YOU SEE IT, TUCKER, ON ONE AREA
WHERE THE PRESIDENT IS SORT OF
REPRESENTING WHERE AMERICANS ARE
AT WHICH IS ON UKRAINE, HE'S
REALLY WALKED A FINE LINE, I
THINK, TOWARDS SUPPORTING THE
UKRAINIANS THE WAY AMERICANS
WANT HIM TO, BUT NOT ESCALATING
IN THE WAY THAT AMERICANS REALLY
DON'T WANT HIM TO, AND ON THAT,
YOU KNOW, THE MEDIA BEATS HIM UP
THE WORST, RIGHT?
BECAUSE HE'S THREATENING THAT
ELITE POINT OF VIEW.
>> Tucker: THAT IS SO TRUE!
AND I THINK -- I MEAN, WHAT DO I
KNOW?
I'M NOT IN TOUCH WITH BIDEN
EVERY DAY, BUT JUST WATCHING HIM
ON TV, HE DID NOT -- HIS FIRST
INSTINCTS WASN'T TO ESCALATE.
HE DIDN'T WANT A WAR WITH
RUSSIA.
AMERICANS WANT TO SUPPORT
UKRAINE.
THEY DON'T WANT A HOT WAR WITH
RUSSIA.
FAIR?
>> EXACTLY.
EXACTLY.
HE'S TRYING HIS BEST TO RESIST
PRESSURE FROM BOTH PARTIES BY
THE WAY FROM THE ELITES IN BOTH
PARTIES BUT NOT FROM THIS SHOW
BECAUSE YOU TELL IT LIKE IT IS,
TUCKER.
>> Tucker: I APPRECIATE THAT.
NO, IT'S CERTAINLY THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY PUSHING HIM.
IT'S TOTALLY CRAZY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COM